foreign
the most terrible poverty is loneliness
and the feeling of being unloved
[Music]
the time you feel lonely is the time you
most need to be by yourself
sometimes you need to be alone not to be
lonely but to enjoy your free time being
yourself
[Music]
the soul that sees Beauty May sometimes
Walk Alone
all great and precious things are lonely
[Music]
a season of loneliness and isolation is
when the caterpillar gets its wings
remember that next time you feel alone
sometimes you need to take a break from
everyone and spend time alone to
experience appreciate and love yourself
there is nothing more lonely and
terrifying than feeling unheard
someday you're going to be all alone so
you need to figure out how to take care
of yourself
the palace leads to fame the market to
Fortune and Solitude to wisdom
[Music]
in a choice between Bad Company and
loneliness the latter is preferable
the lonely person is at home everywhere
[Music]
reading well is one of the great
Pleasures that Solitude can afford you
in the city no one is quiet but many are
lonely in the country people are quiet
but few are lonely
[Music]
people are lonely because they build
walls instead of bridges
loneliness can be conquered only by
those who can bear solitude
the happiest of all lives is a busy
solitude
Columbus discovered no aisle or key as
lonely as himself
leadership is the other side of the coin
of loneliness and he who is a leader
must always act alone and acting alone
except everything alone
[Music]
no one ever discovers the depths of his
own loneliness
the surest cure for vanity is loneliness
the loneliness you feel is actually an
opportunity to reconnect with others and
with yourself
great men are like eagles they build
their nest on some lofty solitude
[Music]
a man can be himself only so long as he
is alone and if he does not love
Solitude he will not love freedom for it
is only when he is alone that he is
truly free
[Music]
the best part about being alone is that
you don't have to answer to anyone you
do what you want
the thing that makes you exceptional if
you are at all is inevitably that which
makes you lonely
[Music]
loneliness is and always has been the
Central and inevitable experience of
every man
[Music]
it takes nothing to join the crowd
it takes everything to stand alone
the only time we waste is the time we
spend thinking we are alone
find company within yourself and you'll
never spend a day alone
find love within yourself and you'll
never have a lonely day
the greatest thing in the world is to
know how to belong to yourself
[Music]
I used to think that the worst thing in
life was to end up all alone it's not
the worst thing in life is to end up
with people that make you feel all alone
[Music]
loneliness adds Beauty to life it puts a
special burn on sunsets and makes night
air smell better
when we cannot bear to be alone it means
we do not properly value the only
companion we will have from birth to
death ourselves
being alone and sitting with our own
thoughts can lead to such growth and
realizations that are rare in our
everyday busy lives
by all means use some time to be alone
salute thyself see what thy Soul doth
where
[Music]
Solitude is the beginning of freedom
loneliness is not a reality it's a
Feeling
constant loneliness his emotional
lameness it damages both physical as
well as mental health
if you never share your feelings with
anyone you are bound to feel lonely
if you meet a loner no matter what they
tell you it's not because they enjoy
solitude
it's because they have tried to blend
into the world and people continue to
disappoint them
[Music]
loneliness is not lack of company
it is lack of purpose
there is nothing outside of yourself
look within everything you want is there
loneliness is about perceiving that no
one is there for you
but Solitude is about making a choice to
be alone with your thoughts
the loneliest moment in someone's life
is when they are watching their whole
world fall apart and all they can do is
stare blankly
if you are afraid of being lonely don't
try to be right
[Music]
it's easy to stand with the crowd but it
takes courage to stand alone
never search for your happiness in
others it will make you feel alone
search for it in yourself you will feel
happy even when you are left alone
dreams have only one owner at a time
that's why dreamers are lonely
[Music]
I've noticed that loneliness gets
stronger when we try to face it down but
gets weaker when we simply ignore it
there is a loneliness in this world so
great that you can see it in the slow
movement of the hands of a clock
[Music]
we're born alone we live alone we die
alone only through our love and
friendships can we create the Illusion
for the moment that we're not alone
[Music]
don't fear Solitude if you are never
alone you cannot know yourself
but don't get too attached to it it may
become an addiction
the woman who follows the crowd will
usually go no further than the crowd
the woman who walks alone is likely to
find herself in places no one has ever
been before
ordinary men hate solitude
but the master makes use of it embracing
his aloneness realizing he is one with
the universe
there is none lonelier than the man who
loves only himself
[Music]
I live in that Solitude which is painful
in youth but delicious in the years of
maturity
it's far better to be unhappy alone than
to be unhappy with someone so far
[Music]